what is up everybody it is axl beats
here for anime uproar and recently we
covered one of the most famous
antagonist groups in anime history being
the phantom troupe so this week i
thought it would be fun to talk about
another iconic antagonist group this
time focusing on fullmetal alchemists
homunculi each of these characters are
representative of one of these seven
deadly sins and their leader father just
might be one of the most interesting
villains anime has ever had to offer and
when you put all of that together it
makes a topic i cannot wait to get into
i will also follow up with the 2003
version which has a few small changes
here or there and a couple very big
changes and of course another big
villain rather than father behind the
scenes before we get into things though
if you enjoy this video and maybe you
want to see more full metal alchemist
content on the channel be sure to leave
a like and if you're new here or if you
just haven't subscribed to anime uproar
yet make this the video that you
subscribe and click that bell to select
all notifications and hey if this video
does particularly well maybe i can talk
animak and gosen into letting me make a
behemoth of a video talking about all
types of alchemy and their respective
alchemists so be sure to show your
support down below you can also show
some support by following anime uproar
on twitter and instagram at anime uproar
or you can follow myself at excellionyt
of course this video will contain
fullmetal alchemist brotherhood and
fullmetal alchemist spoilers so please
proceed with caution you have been
warned when it comes to brotherhood i
think the best place to start is
arguably the most recognizable of the
seven named monkeylight created by
father with lust
full metal alchemist
now i know what you're thinking but i
promise i only like her because of her
very integral role in the story she is
so impactful through the entire thing
it's great also she is extremely hot
lust in accordance to her name wears a
tight black dress that has a very low
cut she has long black hair and of
course she has a pretty flirtatious way
of talking lust in many ways acts as an
archetypal black widow luring men in
with her looks and then savagely and
sadistically attacking them what is
interesting about lust in particular is
that she doesn't exactly follow any of
the traits of her namesake not
traditionally at least while every other
homunculus acts according to their title
lust isn't exactly going around trying
to sleep with people instead she
weaponizes her sexuality and presses
that way of thinking into her opponents
that said while she doesn't show lust in
the traditional sense it could
definitely be argued that she does have
a sense of bloodlust seeming to get a
real feeling of fulfillment from
torturing and killing people she also
definitely had a sense of superiority
when it comes to humans in general to
her they are simple weak and naive
however at the same time that naivety
seemed to be something that she found at
least somewhat charming though this
might be more in line with when a person
sees their pet do something stupid you
know it's really cute but also still
very dumb all to say lust is a very cold
and vindictive woman who loves nothing
more than to play on the well
lustfulness of men and at the same time
when it comes to the other homunculi her
relationships are more akin to how
people might see their family some of
them she doesn't really get along with
some of them she does but the most
notable relationship that she has is
definitely with gluttony acting as a
pseudo big sister or mother figure for
him and keeping him under some kind of
control now let's move on to what she
can actually do in terms of abilities as
a baseline all monkey lies share the
majority of their powers and have one or
two unique traits to them these shared
ones usually include things like being
incredibly strong and fast having never
aging bodies that don't get sick not
needing to eat or drink and being able
to nearly instantly heal any damage that
they take
effectively they are just near immortal
superhumans powered by philosopher
stones now there is of course a limit to
the healing that they can do as lust
herself finds out when she comes face to
face with mustang but in general this is
kind of the rule of thumb list for all
humungous there are some exceptions to
the list and if they are really big
standouts i'll mention them as we go but
this is just a good baseline so that
said lust's unique ability is ultimate
spear allowing her to grow her fingers
into long piercing spikes that to the
best of my knowledge don't have any real
limit on their distance and they can go
through just about anything this allows
lust to turn her fingers into bullets
that launch themselves into who or
whatever she points them at while these
tend to be used more as piercing tools
she can also use them as blades to slice
with as well
it's a very simple and straightforward
ability but it is extremely effective
all the same which does tend to be the
trend for most homunculus abilities now
also something shared with every named
monkey lie in brotherhood is that each
of them is killed in a way which
somewhat correlates to their sin for
example lust was killed by roy mustang
someone who is famously a womanizer
full metal alchemist
next up let's go with gluttony as for
the name he's kind of just a tubby bald
guy something i've really liked about
him though is his face he has these
small white beady eyes and a massive
mouth it looks kind kinda goofy but when
you combine it with his very childlike
personality it makes him very likeable
which makes his horror moments all that
more effective through contrast speaking
of as you might expect for a monster
named gluttony his whole thing is eating
people particularly liking to eat women
but at the end of the day he probably
won't complain about getting any food of
any kind gluttony was always such an
interesting character me as despite the
dark side that he had he was also
probably one of the most pure and at
times human characters as well at least
among the homunculi he shows actual
sadness when he learns about lust dying
he is overjoyed when greed is reborn and
there are a ton of little nuggets of
emotion from gluttony throughout the
entire series which really shine through
because of his childishness and speaking
of his childishness that is the exact
reason why he is typically paired with
lust who kind of guides him by the hand
and keeps him in check but all that said
it isn't like gluttony is a drastically
complex character at the end of the day
he's just a child-like man obsessed with
eating people and that's kind of it as
far as his unique ability goes though
firstly he has a very strong sense of
smell which he can use to hunt people
down but more importantly and much more
iconically his stomach is basically a
pocket dimension this is because when
father made gluttony he was trying to
make a new gate of truth however he
failed and gluttony's gate instead leads
to a domain between the actual gate and
the normal world gluttony can pull
people into his gate with a beam that
comes from his stomach and once they're
inside the only way for them to get out
is to perform human transmutation now
normally this would lead them to the
gate of truth where they would meet
truth and lose an arm a leg or whatever
else however when used within gluttony's
dimension the gate instead leads back to
the normal world circumventing the
entire process so as far as we could
tell we don't lose anything this way and
finally gluttony's ironic end comes when
he is devoured by pride
full metal alchemist
next up let's cover envy this is a
character i didn't really like when i
first watched the show but upon
re-watching it last year i found him to
be a lot more sympathetic of the
character still kind of a dickling but
better the second time around for sure
out of all the ha monkey lie envy hates
humans the most seeming to take the most
pride out of torturing them and making
them suffer the only one who this is
even comparable with is maybe pride
which to be fair they're both kind of
horrific monsters we see envy taking
pride in the fact that he played a role
in the incident which started the ishval
in war as well as just in general for
ruining the lives of countless people
all of this though stems from what his
name suggests envy specifically for
humanity's ability to endure as well as
for their knack to form close bonds
which cause them to love and support one
another as a homunculus he never really
experienced that and as such he aims to
destroy it when he sees it in others i
know i typically talk about appearance
first but with envy we kind of have to
talk about his ability because it's tied
to his appearance envy is a shapeshifter
being able to turn into anything or
anyone as long as it doesn't exceed the
mass of his true form and this true form
is kind of massive so it's usually not
an issue he can also change individual
parts of his body into things like
snakes or even giant portions of his
true form at will so it doesn't have to
be a 100 transformation kind of thing
along with this he can also imitate
people's personalities and voices but it
isn't a perfect impersonation his
overconfidence tends to shine through
and those who know the person he's
trying to imitate very intimately can
usually see through the disguise now on
to envy's true form this comes in two
parts firstly in a massive green lizard
monster with a dog's face long black
hair multiple eyes and a back that is
covered in the faces of humans who
represent those who died in xerxes it is
absolute nightmare fuel and of the
entire series it's probably one of the
images that stayed in my head the
longest after first watching it however
after most of his philosopher's stone is
destroyed he becomes a small green
parasite that can attach to people or to
mannequin homunculi and can even control
them if he bites into them of course he
eventually dies in this smaller form
choosing to take his own life when
edward explains that the homunculus is
in fact jealous of humanity's friendship
a reality that envy has been avoiding
his entire life and when faced with it
directly is something which led to him
removing his own philosopher's stone
full metal alchemist
our fourth homunculus is greed greed is
a surprisingly wise homunculus who is as
you might assume very very greedy his
worldview is one that suggests everyone
in the world is greedy while he himself
wants money women's status fame and
everything else the world has to offer
including eternal life he also argues
that everyone wants something and even
the desire to do good is a form of greed
greed is beyond charismatic and charming
and yes super narcissistic but in most
cases if he's not trying to take
something he's pretty easy going and
comfortable something which might stem
from his unique ability the ultimate
shield greed is able to harden the
carbon all over his body to make a dense
black material that coats his entire
body that is as durable as diamond he
can also cover specific points of his
body or inside his body as well and it
makes him essentially impervious to
damage with one of the only real
weaknesses being transmuting that carbon
to something less durable like when ed
changed it to graphite now combine this
ultimate shield with the general
homunculus trait of regeneration and
immortality and you get someone who is
extremely difficult to kill speaking of
difficult to kill he was killed ish by
father when his greed and goals were
revealed father elected to have him
drowned in molten gold which i mean gold
and greed is a pretty easy parallel to
make however this was not the end of
greed's story as after lust is killed
father revives greed as a philosopher's
stone and decides to place it inside
ling greed's memories were wiped and he
was reborn and as a result he is
entirely loyal to father once taking
over ling's body however eventually his
memories flood back into him and he once
again defects along the way ling's mind
is awakened as well within the new greed
and he kind of acts as a
pseudo-conscience
not exactly a moral conscience but at
least a voice of reason from time to
time over their new cohabitants greed
even begins opening up to ling him even
explaining that what he really desired
most in the world was to have people in
his life that were close to him
something that is very easy to parallel
with envy this new greed was such an
interesting character and his growth is
really put on display in the final fight
where not only does he stop ling from
sacrificing himself and being pulled
into father but he also decides to heal
ling before he himself dies an act of
generosity to the only true friend he
has ever made
full metal alchemist
moving on to brotherhood sloth and like
we can all agree this is the worst one
right between both series
he is this hulking burly man who just
drudges forward until his mission is
complete all so he can finally sleep
once it's done this is kind of a
difficult homunculus to talk about
because even more so than gluttony sloth
is a very flat and one-dimensional
character his role in the story was to
dig the transmutation circle under a
mistress and he just doesn't really do
much outside of that on top of that he
doesn't really have a special ability
per se he uses chains and fights which
are kind of interesting and his physical
strength and durability is pretty up
there even being able to take a
point-blank shot from a tank fairly
easily however the closest thing we
could really call to sloth's special
ability is his tendency to dash at
people at incredible speeds that are
often uncontrollable on top of not being
able to be easily controlled you have to
couple in that sloth is incredibly naive
and very clumsy often leading to him
making mistakes which can definitely be
an issue when you take into account that
he heals slower than any of his siblings
obviously with the exception of wrath
who doesn't heal sloth's ironic end
comes in the form of him overworking his
philosopher's stone when he takes too
much damage once the stone is depleted
he shortly passes away and he finally
gets the rest he desired
full metal alchemist
next up is a character who is likely the
creepiest in the series being selene
bradley pride this was the first
homunculus ever created by father and
it's just kind of pure malice incarnate
what made it a thousand times creepier
than it already was is that it takes the
form of a little kid as the name
suggests pride is very self-important
seeing humans as toys or slaves and
trying to convince his siblings to do
the same this superiority and arrogance
carries on into his fights as well as he
typically taunts his opponents to see if
he can get them to make mistakes
furthermore because he thinks he's so
far above his opponents he will often
underestimate them finally you probably
don't want to be on pride's team when it
comes to battle as if he has the
opportunity he will eat you to gain an
advantage just like he did with gluttony
now you might be asking what exactly
pride does when it comes to battle well
that comes in the form of him
controlling a massive shadow with tons
of eyes and mouths he can shape it into
long tendrils that can slice through
anything very much in a more versatile
version of lust's ultimate spear however
this does not come without its own set
of weaknesses as his abilities come from
shadows he needs to be in a place where
shadows are present so anywhere that is
completely dark or anywhere that has too
bright of lights where shadows aren't
being cast you can't really do much with
his abilities honestly a pretty good
trade-off to make because anyone who is
in the range of his abilities can be
freely manipulated absorbed or just
straight up attacked whenever he wants
speaking of absorption though if pride
does choose to eat someone he will gain
their abilities their knowledge and
their weaknesses for example when he
eats gluttony he gets his scent of smell
and hunger when he absorbs kimberley he
learns some form of alchemy and when he
eats the goldtooth doctor he learns his
knowledge of human transmutation
basically on top of being a shadow
monster he's also kirby pride was
defeated in brotherhood when he tries to
take over edward a human who he deemed
to be lower than himself as he tries
this kimberley intervenes giving ed the
chance to counter-attack and defeat the
monkeyless this brings out his true form
which looks like a small fetus that is
even weaker than the humans he looked
down on
full metal alchemist
and that brings us to our final sin
named homunculus in brotherhood being
wrath fuhrer king bradley unlike his
siblings bradley is a human-based
homunculus giving him his own set of
unique traits he was an orphan raised
with the name of prospective fuhrer 12
in a secret program created by father
and the amestres military owen hopes to
produce the perfect ruler in this
program students would learn politics
military strategy swordplay and whatever
else might be required of a true king
each was also taught that everyone
around them was only there to become
stepping stones for their own greatness
if they kill the classmate that only
meant that the other student wasn't
worthy to be king at the end of this
very brutal training a philosopher's
stone was injected into the candidates
and only number 12 survived making him
the first human-based temunculus and
having him be granted the name king
bradley based on his talents attained
from the program bradley quickly rose
through the military and became fuhrer
getting married and adopting a son named
saleem later revealed to be pride
bradley acted and led a mistress in a
way which facilitated father's wishes be
it fighting a war to create a new
philosopher's stone or keeping other
military personnel blind to what was
truly happening bradley let's be real is
one of the most badass characters in the
series and a lot of this comes from his
ability to be a phenomenal actor he can
go from playful and charming to
overwhelmingly confident and threatening
at the drop of a hat making him one of
the strongest presences in the entire
story and of course fitting to a
character in his position bradley is
overflowing with charisma that is even
attractive to those watching i cannot
think of a single person who does not
love this character but let's talk about
what he can actually do as i said he is
a human-based homunculus which makes him
a little bit special at its core this
meant that he was the only homunculus
that can age in most cases this would be
a negative but if you're holding public
office and you live in the public eye it
might become a bit weird if he just
stayed 20 years old forever eventually
people would catch on that something was
up furthermore while bradley is stronger
faster and more agile than most of the
characters in the series this is all
just him and it doesn't come from his
philosopher's stone at all he also
doesn't get the regeneration or
immortality attributed from being a
homunculus but what he does get is his
special ability the ultimate eye with
this he can essentially see shortly into
the future and perfectly see his
surroundings this combined with his
god-like reflexes make him incredibly
difficult to hit let alone to beat in
combat a good example of this is when we
see him fight greedling foo and
buccaneer more or less all at once and
almost not taking any hits until a
surprise attack knocks him off balance
that said his aging body can't always
keep up with what his eye predicts in
every situation but despite this he can
still move and react fast enough to
deflect machine gun rounds with a sword
cut a tank shell in half and just more
or less dominate everything in front of
him his eye also allows him to analyze
his opponents seeing their strengths
weaknesses and what movement they might
make just by looking at them wrath is
eventually defeated by the reformed scar
and dies with a peaceful smile on his
face
full metal alchemist
and that brings us to the final
brotherhood homunculus for this video
the dwarf in the flask father created
from hohenheim's blood through
experiments in xerxes the dwarf in the
flask was produced with a wealth of
understanding of the universe
particularly in the field of alchemy
living with the young hohenheim then
named slave 23 the homunculus would go
on to teach him enough to earn his
freedom things like literacy and of
course alchemy over time the dwarf grew
jealous of humanity their freedom their
cohabitation and their support system
all while he was locked away and lonely
in his flask all of the sins that he
removed from himself were still very
much in play while he was in this form
he began to lose self-esteem as he was
alone and replaced it with hubris those
humans that he was envious of knew
nothing they were beneath him and as
someone who understood alchemy he was
effectively a god no no he was greater
than god
the king of xerxes eventually called for
the dwarf in the flask and asked him to
help gain immortality the homunculus
agreed to help ordering the construction
of a nationwide transmutation circle
along with the slaughter of countless
citizens however he lied to the king
rather than granting immortality to the
monarch the dwarf in the flask instead
granted it to both himself and hohenheim
turning them both into living
philosopher stones and turning the king
into just another sacrifice horrified at
what happened hohenheim decides to
abandon homunculus and as the years
passed the homunculus would go on to
pull the flaws from himself and produce
children the embodiments of his lust
gluttony envy greed sloth pride and
wrath and through this he gained his new
name father his ultimate goal in the
story was to attain the power of god
something that he could do by repeating
what he had once done in xerxes but this
time with a mestress this was eventually
successful as he devoured god and became
essentially almighty however hohenheim
had a solution using the moon's shadow
as a massive transmutation circle he
released all of the emestrian souls
within father and with them no longer
fueling him he was not fully able to
control the power of god his body
started straining this fight continues
for some time but the longer it goes on
the more and more father begins to
struggle to contain god and as he
struggles to keep this power within
himself he is ultimately defeated by a
massive group effort of nearly every
relevant living character in the story
at this point ed lands one final blow
and all of the remaining souls as well
as the god within him are released
leaving his body to crumble his soul
then appears in front of truth in his
original form as the dwarf from the
flask truth berates him for his actions
and mentality he had removed so much of
himself and swallowed god hoping to
become perfect rather than embracing who
he was truth ultimately takes away the
freedom that father had sacrificed
xerxes to acquire by sealing him beyond
the gate ending the homunculus's story
as far as abilities go i mean
all of them right father had perfect
control over alchemy and he is a living
philosopher stone he is immortal ungodly
strong fast smart the dude could just
about do everything that he wanted to
and that was kind of before swallowing
god so it's a little bit difficult to
describe everything that he's able to do
as just there's too much just know he's
basically all-powerful and able to do
whatever he wants in his prime but that
wraps up the brotherhood homunculus so
next let's take a look at their 2003
counterparts hot take by the way i think
the monkey light in 2003 are infinitely
more interesting i think that their
method of creation is so much more
poetically powerful and it adds a lot to
the story which just is lost in
brotherhood canon or not that's just my
opinion obviously there are some
elements from brotherhood that i think
far outweigh the 2003 version but when
it comes to homunculus as a group i
think 2003 has a little bit of an edge
so homunculus in the 2003 version are
not created by father because father
does not exist rather they are produced
when a human transmutation is attempted
the transmutation as always will fail
and rather than a person being brought
back to life a new being is created
instead a monster with their genetics
and some of their memories but still
entirely its own if this monster is fed
red stones they will become more
powerful and eventually a full-fledged
homunculus what i really like about this
is that it makes the consequences for
their actions go beyond just themselves
ed doesn't just lose an arm and a leg he
creates an actual monster in the world
the taboo of human transmutation and
alchemy is a form of social contract
there is a responsibility and promise
that comes with being an alchemist that
you will not breach this and as such it
makes sense for there to be real world
social consequences when that contract
is breached all of the homunculus in the
2003 version also share a weakness in
that if the bones of their original body
are brought nearby they are weakened and
if it's close enough they are entirely
paralyzed now i'm only going to explain
the major changes and the homunculus
origins because otherwise it would get
very repetitive so just keep that in
mind going
forward full metal alchemist
starting with lust she was created when
scar's brother attempted to bring back
his dead lover and as such he was made
in his lover's image which can i just
say
nice less personality is largely similar
between the virgins however what she
lusts for in this version is to become
human to meet this end she will lead
alchemist to seek out the philosopher's
stone hoping that she can take it and
give it to dante who would use it to
make her human however she eventually
learns that dante is lying to her and
defects ultimately leading dante to send
wrath to kill her as she dies she
wonders where homunculus will go once
they pass on while lust is still pretty
savage at times in this version the much
more human element i think goes a long
way into making her a very sympathetic
character
full metal alchemist
gluttony in the 2003 version is almost
the same as brotherhood until he learns
of lust death of course this time dante
lobotomizes him ultimately leading him
to become a pure sense of gluttony
devouring everything and everyone in his
path including eventually dante in 2003
he is also not a false gate of truth
rather he was created by dante to drink
the red water and to consume human flesh
until they condensed in his stomach and
made a new philosopher's stone however
the core themes of his character being
one that is created by father or dante
to meet their ultimate goal is still
something that is very much held intact
full metal alchemist
envy in the 2003 version was the first
homunculus created and was created when
hohenheim tried to revive he and dante's
dead son envy hated hohenheim for
abandoning both he and his mother and as
you might imagine he was a bit envious
of the elric brothers who received some
of hohenheim's affection and fatherly
love unlike the other homunculi he has
no real desire to become human instead
he just wants to kill as many people as
he can
full metal alchemist
2003 greed was created by dante and much
like his brotherhood counterpart he
eventually rebelled against his creator
he wanted a truly immortal body trying
to get edward to bind his soul to armor
just like al's had been of course there
is no greedling in this version as ling
is not a character but it is also
important to note that greed is another
character who doesn't really care about
becoming human so those are the ones
that more or less translate somewhat
directly from brotherhood to this
version the rest are completely
reimagined characters for the most part
full metal alchemist
wrath in this version was created when
izumi curtis tried to revive her
stillborn son when the resurrected
corpse was not her child she decided to
give it back to the gate but as the gate
closed in front of her she began to hear
the baby cry and regretted not keeping
it as wrath grew older he eventually
opened the gate himself but emerged with
no memories he had found himself on yok
island and eventually was taken in by
the curtis family for a short time until
the military captured him and envy took
the opportunity to feed him red stones
unlocking his true personality from here
wrath decides to join the homunculi
where he latched onto sloth as a new
adopted mother wrath in 2003 had a
powerful bloodlust after eating the red
stones very different to whom he was
prior for much of the story wrath also
had edward's missing arm and leg which
resulted in him being a homunculi who
could perform alchemy making him a very
powerful opponent
full metal alchemist
sloth is probably one of my favorite
characters in the 2003 version and maybe
even in full metal alchemist in general
which is ironic because of how much i
dislike the other version of sloth she
was created by edward when he tried to
revive his mother and as such she looks
just like her sloth in this case does
not refer to slow movement or laziness
like it does in brotherhood it instead
refers to her apathetic personality as
for her unique ability she can turn
parts of herself into flowing water that
she can kind of control at will she
plays a very interesting role in the
story as she shares some of trisha
elric's memories and is very much
disturbed by them but at the same time
she uses the memory of trisha within ed
al and hohenheim to make openings that
she can take advantage of
full metal alchemist
finally we have 2003's pride which of
course
is fewer king bradley rather than him
being wrath like he was in brotherhood
he plays very much a similar role racing
through the military to become fuhrer
and manipulating a mistress to produce a
philosopher's stone there are a few big
differences between the king bradleys
though namely this version is still able
to regenerate when injured making him
even more dangerous he even allows
mustang to blow him up and regenerates
from next to nothing furthermore this
time he is much more savage than he was
in brotherhood which says a lot because
that bradley was also kind of a monster
the only reason they were able to defeat
him in this version is because as his
house burns down salim brings him a
treasure from his locked safe he did
this in hopes of protecting what he
thought was his father's most prized
possession however the treasure was the
skull of the man he had been born from
in a fin of rage bradley strangles his
son to death and afterwards due to being
weakened by his closeness to the skull
mustang is able to take him down just as
he had with lust in brotherhood
full metal alchemist
and the last character we have to cover
is dante the big bad from the original
fullmetal alchemist dante transfers her
soul from person to person using a
philosopher's stone to prolong her life
four centuries ago she started doing the
nasty with hohenheim and they were able
to live together for centuries because
of this ability they even had a son who
unfortunately died at 18.
as mentioned previously hohenheim tries
to revive this boy and he would
eventually become envy together dante
and hohenheim would go on to destroy two
major cities as they prolong their own
life turning the inhabitants of these
cities into philosopher's stones and
jumping into new bodies
eventually hohenheim would leave dante
though and fell in love with tricia
elric now alone dante began creating
homunculi feeding the husts that
remained from human transmutation red
stones and convincing them to work for
her if they did so she promised to make
them human once she got the
philosopher's stone this was of course a
lie and instead she only wanted to
extend her own life the only homunculi
who knew the truth were pride and envy
pride went along with it because he
received a position of power while envy
just wanted to murder people ultimately
dante's immortality was far from perfect
when she jumped to her new host she
always left behind a part of her soul
becoming more and more hollow each time
she did this as a result with her final
jump in the series her soul is having
difficulty sustaining a human body this
doesn't entirely matter all that much in
the grand scheme of things though as
either way she is devoured by gluttony
and that's it a look at both versions of
fullmetal alchemists homunculi and their
leaders there are definitely good parts
of both the viciousness of brotherhood's
monkey life and the humanity in the 2003
versions personally i think i like the
2003 versions more as a whole but i
totally understand liking the other
version more to me lust wrath and sloth
in 2003 are just so much more
interesting whereas bradley and greed
are much more interesting in brotherhood
also i think father is probably a little
bit more interesting than dante although
dante not so bad herself and that kind
of only leaves envy and gluttony envy is
a total toss-up both versions are very
good for different reasons and gluttony
is just kind of gluttony so you know
doesn't super matter but i would love to
hear your own opinions in the comments
down below which version of homunculi do
you like best and which homunculus is
your favorite finally if you guys
enjoyed this fullmetal alchemist video
and you want to see more please leave a
like and if you're new to anime uproar
remember to subscribe and ring that bell
by selecting all notifications you can
guarantee that you will not miss any
future videos and of course you can also
follow anime uproar on twitter and
instagram at anime uproar or you can
follow myself at excellionyt i want to
give a big thank you to all of our anime
uproar patrons who make videos like this
one possible special thanks to alpha
sigma who is an absolute mad lad and
disciple of lord twego himself and of
course our the one tier patrons the ones
who rise above all other clans these
being ingrada patahepha al-jatal
hinokami and water the toasted chi the
spike 8227 dylan isadore spidey life
tenell tungsten tarkis baked buddhist
and monkey d quilly and finally thank
you to all of our pro hero tier patrons
the one and only gilgamesh the
red-haired raven angel cruz rathuen de
ora very gucci alicia octor bonnie parks
joanne garcia ted not ted fatboy games
corey mcgowan and soul ray slice and
dice if you enjoy our videos and feel
like they provide some kind of value to
you please consider checking out our
patreon through the link in the
description anyone who supports the
channel with even a single dollar has
access to our exclusive patreon only
discord and your name will appear at the
end of videos just like all of these
phenomenal people but for now i want to
thank you all so much for watching and
until next time remember to stay active
[Music]
you